hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel and today i am very excited
to announce that i have made the
decision
after about a year of streaming
consistently
to partner on twitch this is something
that if you've watched a lot of my
streams or
even recent q a type videos i've
toyed with the idea of it on and off for
a really long time and was very
uncertain about doing it as someone who
was previously streaming simultaneously
on
youtube twitch and facebook that meant
managing three chats and three very
different kinds of
cultures uh and eventually i decided
that
partnering on twitch made made sense and
seemed like a good idea
so first up if you're watching this
video at the moment it published i am
doing
my first ever partner stream over on
twitch
right now i published this so that it
would type out so that would be a thing
it's very exciting it's i don't know it
feels like a cool thing even though i've
had that partner invite sitting in my
inbox for about a year
it's um weirdly exciting to to to be a
part of
this thing and be like more involved in
the twitch ecosystem and be able to
squad stream with my friends and all
that stuff
so as for why i decided to do this after
streaming on multiple platforms all at
once
i previously didn't want to because i'm
generally against exclusivity deals i
think they're pretty sucky in general
and i have been on youtube for such a
long time that it didn't seem right to
leave the youtube audience and go to
another platform when i'd already built
that audience on youtube but i actually
think this will make my youtube channel
better
but okay yeah there are a bunch of
reasons first i think youtube channels
are stronger when they do edited videos
so
i will continue to have edited content
uh including the podcast
up here on youtube and we'll also take
any streams that i particularly like and
edit them down
and as a person who has never done
overlays or like you know the
sub shout outs or any of that um i don't
imagine that any of that will be in the
edited down content but for like a
stream that's two hours i plan to have
like a 15 minute highlight video
kind of thing it's also just that my
youtube has become this like weird grab
bag of different kinds of content which
is kind of intentional just as a
reminder it is a personal channel
this youtube channel is not a gaming
channel it has always been intended to
be
my personal youtube channel where i just
largely end up talking about video games
anyway
um because that's what interests me the
most but i feel like it makes more sense
to have like a more consistent
kind of content on youtube and move the
big old long streams elsewhere
um and edit them down for youtube videos
instead so they would be kind of more
similar to a fun house video i do have
some edited streams like check out my
resident evil 2 edit
i think that's a really good stream edit
i was very proud of that one i think
it's very funny
but it will be basically better youtube
content and not just big long unedited
streams where i'm like talking to chat
and stuff part of it is also
that uh because youtube has a different
culture and i did speak to other
creators about this before making this
decision
uh youtube chat is often just
a lot more negative than twitch chat i
think that's because twitch
has more of a community focus obviously
starting
a very long time ago as a streaming
website where youtube didn't and that
doesn't bother me
uh really ever but it does mean that the
youtube chat ends up with people just
arguing with each other a lot of the
time and sometimes i don't even know
what they're arguing about the youtube
chat
which has made me say on multiple
occasions for the people here who are
cool just come over to the twitch chat
instead
because the culture there is like just a
lot more fun i started to have a
preference to reading twitch chat versus
youtube chat
uh not to fault any of my youtube mods
who've done a wonderful job but just
the culture is different and like i said
i did talk to other creators and i was
like is this
like am i wrong about this and they're
like no it's 100 a thing that youtube
chat can just be a lot more toxic
all the console wars trash people get
caught up in just doesn't seem to be as
much of a thing on twitch
and i had people in my community reach
out to me and kind of tell me that over
time they had noticed that on my youtube
chat
and came over to twitch anyway to the
extent where i now when i stream have
more viewers on twitch than i do on
youtube
anyway because the good people were kind
of noticing that happening
and leaving the youtube streams part of
it is also that i have made
uh not technically but virtually zero
dollars from streaming on twitch i have
always made absolutely zero dollars no
subs
no no tips no bits i don't even know
what the lingo is
i'm that unfamiliar with this kind of
thing i do
technically sometimes get ad revenue if
i leave a youtube stream up and i am
going to make another channel um as a
sidebar
which i will leave a link to in the
description for vods for people who
don't catch twitch streams but still do
want to watch that content so i will
just upload them later on to youtube
like the next day or something uh but
ultimately as someone who
every single stream that i did in
february bar one which was for a
cake shop that i thought was very cool
was for charity uh every single one
i think we raised in total across
everything
probably about fifty thousand dollars
this month which is
pretty [ __ ] cool and i feel like it's
just smarter if i
figure out a way to use any income that
comes from twitch
to further those courses as someone who
is not a professional content creator or
full-time content creator and does not
do this as a way to make money it's like
that doesn't mean i can't be smarter
about it um i don't know how that's
going to look because i don't know what
taxes are going to look like
and i do really want to pay my team of
mods who on twitch are very wonderful
so i don't know what that is going to be
i don't know how much money i will make
if really any
i'm really not sure still very new to
twitch don't know how it works but that
was kind of my thought process that
there's a lot of good that can be done
out of monetizing streaming which is
something that i have not done at all
up until this point now related to me
not being a professional content creator
or full-time content creator whatsoever
this won't actually
really change anything this won't change
the frequency which width i stream
um it's not going to make me have
scheduled streams i might tell people
like the day before but a thing that's
very important to me as someone who
has a job that is quite challenging and
quite demanding and that i absolutely
love
is that i don't want to tie myself to a
schedule in case there's a really big
work day where i'm just too tired
afterwards um
none of that stuff is going to change
i'm not going to become more of a
professional streamer by any means so i
still won't be scheduling when i'm
streaming uh it's just kind of a thing
that if you follow me on twitch
i just kind of do it some days try to do
twice a week generally
but if i'm not feeling it or i'm too
busy that's the reality of that
so i don't want the partner status to
change people's expectations from me
because i am still
not a streamer by which i mean
professional streamer obviously that is
still
not me not something i ever want to do
will ever do i have absolutely no desire
to do it as anything other than a hobby
i have absolutely no desire to do it
full-time or professionally
ever so i don't want people to have that
expectation and i am a little bit
concerned about that but yeah
realistically
it'll still be streaming the same amount
which is generally like twice a week one
thing that i think will change in a
positive way
is being a little bit more integrated
into the twitch community is that i have
a lot of friends who twitch stream all
the time
and previously like i've not been able
to do any of the squad stream stuff i've
not been eligible for a lot of twitch
campaigns
um because even though i have i guess
113 000 followers thank you everyone
i'm still not a partner or even an
affiliate so there's a lot of things
that i've been borrowed from
um that should maybe involve some more
cool collaboration stuff with other
people on the platform i'm definitely
planning to
do more recurring streams with friends
um and yeah squad streaming stuff that i
feel like i've always been missing out
on which is kind of a bummer but that's
mostly it i'm very excited about it
i'm really excited about the idea of
emotes
uh my mods have already been kind of
throwing some ideas at me and i think
that'll be a really fun
opportunity to hire a cool artist and
make cool stuff
for anyone who's subscribed i don't know
that i'll do the monthly newsletters
thing it's it's not something i'm trying
to even
incentivize you towards really if
anything i would probably just like tell
people
in advance what charity i might be
raising money for that that month or
something along those lines but that is
that is part of it that
definitely does appeal to me is i feel
like it opens up some some cool
opportunities
but generally yes um i think it'll make
my youtube channel better
and less of a mess and less just like a
bunch of long streams that a lot of the
time i unlist anyway
there are still some things that i will
definitely stream on youtube and not on
twitch occasionally
um like play watch listen live will
always be on youtube because the podcast
is on youtube
any of the like journalist reviewer kind
of streams that i've done
um which are like the last of us review
chat and i did one for
cyberpunk i did too for cyberpunk
actually people's impressions planning
to do one for one division
this saturday um anything that's very
editorial
will still live on youtube because i
feel like that kind of informative
content is youtube content whereas the
gameplay stuff will stick
to twitch i think that's pretty much it
i'm very excited i hope you'll
join me over on twitch if that's the
thing you're excited about i don't have
any plans for the look to change
but i have like sub counters or any of
that kind of stuff i'm still going to
keep it very
low-fi cause i don't know what i'm doing
is the truth but i'm excited to do it
and i think we can uh make some cool
stuff happen
on the platform and and yeah i look
forward to
to beginning this journey what's up come
hang out twitch.tv such carolinas are
if you aren't already over there my chat
is a fun time
play any kind of game at any point in
time obviously this was the
five and a half hour stream and i think
the one before that valheim was a pretty
long stream too
i also for anyone who has not been uh
following me on twitch actually have
done a bunch of twitch exclusive streams
i've done podcasts that are only on
twitch
and editing videos that are only on
twitch so sometimes if i'm editing
something like editing a video i'll
stream it to twitch as well at the same
time
so i do actually already kind of do more
streams on twitch that don't exist on
youtube um that are kind of just for
things that are more casual because
again i just have this this vision of
these two platforms as being very
different kinds of content so yeah
that's it for me today everyone i look
forward to seeing you there
i'm lana i'll see you guys next time bye